et maintenant une petite idée de sortie
cinéma tout petit même puisque le film
s'appelle minuscule les aventures d'une
colonie de fourmis à la conquête d'une
boîte de sucre
grâce à dominique poncet et georges
priol nous en découvrons les quicks il
était une fois une très intrépide petite
coccinelle qui au cours de ses
pérégrinations à l'été d une armée de
fourmis noires très gentille à gagner
une guerre contre des fourmis rouges
très méchante minuscule ça commence donc
comme un conte de fées et se poursuit
comme un film d'aventurés à la indiana
jones
sauf qu'ici ce sont des faux millet pas
des humains qui sont les stars du film
dans cette aventure on voulait un
conflit et quoi de plus pratique que des
fourmis rouges et des fourmis noires qui
sont la guerre donc on s'est dit oui à
londres
partant avec des fourmis et puis en plus
il fournit en a partout vraiment partout
partout sur la terre donc on s'est dit
c'est universel je pense ça va parler à
tout le monde mais pour transformer des
fourmis en héroïne capable d'émouvoir et
de passionner les petits comme des
grands
il a fallu les redessiner d'après nature
évidemment
en fait on a récupéré des vrais vraies
photos de fourmies ont les arts
travaille on les a utilisés et on a fait
un travail pour les rendre plus à 28
n'ajoutez des yeux avec des pupilles ça
nous permet de un petit peu avoir une
palette d'émotions quand même un petit
peu plus large
et oui c'était important qu'ils aient
une petite tête qui nous plaisent la
lure des fourmis et de chaque insecte du
film une fois défini les réalisateurs se
sont attelés au scénario
ils l'ont d'abord dessiné plan par plan
puis sont allés tourner chaque scène en
décors réels en l'occurrence le parc du
mercantour
ensuite sur chaque image ils ont
réintroduit les insectes en les animant
un travail de titan
mais le résultat est là minuscule est un
bijou de poésie de suspense et d'humour
sans paroles ni commentaire mais avec
une bande-son inouïe et avec l'apport de
la 3d